[Music]
mr. Modi I'm about to travel to Beijing
on business may I wear a dust mask to
guard against the pollution it's to
Beijing has polluted if you're wondering
if a mask will offend your host and it
won't many natives have adopted this
practice too just don't delude yourself
into thinking a skimpy mask for the
sword favored by many Chinese urbanites
will do much good
cheap surgical type masks make you look
awesome sure but they don't filter many
harmful particles a local anti-pollution
organization recommends a higher quality
mask with replaceable filters made of
charcoal a substance whose manufacturer
ironically contributes to air pollution
not recommended by any means is trying
to enliven your painfully dreary masks
with drawings done in
permanent marker I'm mr. know-it-all
which means I already know whether or
not you are interested in clicking on
the subscribe button you are